in the age of imperialism there were few
places in asia which got through without
coming under direct rule by a foreign
power
now in the middle east there was one
glaring exception iran who was never
conquered even briefly
but the question is why why was iran
never colonized
so as of the 19th century the borders of
iran or persia as it was known then
looked like this
it was ruled by the kajar dynasty whose
primary concern wasn't european powers
but the ottoman empire to its west
however as the ottomans declined two
more powers stepped into the void to
potentially threaten persia
the first was the russian empire whose
expansion eastward and southward brought
it into a series of conflict
persians by the mid 19th century the
russians had taken this territory and
was now a major trade partner of persia
and it was shortly after this that
persia came into contact with britain
who clashed with them and the qajar
dynasty lost control of these
economically important lands
now the rulers of persia at this point
weren't silly and they knew that persia
was declining and that the two powers
weren't going to stop until they had
control of persia in its entirety
persia's rulers knew that they couldn't
put up much resistance to either empire
in the event of an invasion so they did
the only thing that they could
play both britain and russia off against
each other and this did work for a time
but over the course of the late 19th
century britain's economic control
continued to grow
and thereafter something important
happened persia struck oil
a lot of oil which other nations wanted
britain's economic influence led to the
persian government signing overall oil
rights in the early 20th century to the
anglo-persian oil company
nowadays called bp 1907 also saw the
closest thing to the colonization of
persia
the anglo-russian convention in which
britain and russia carved the country up
into spheres of economic influence with
a little remaining free
thus persia's position as a state which
sat partially in both nations spheres of
influence kept it from formally being an
imperial domain of either
however when world war one rolled up it
did cause issues when the ottoman empire
declared war on the ontart persia being
somewhat aligned with them became a
target
the british and russians maintained
their zones of influence there and the
ottomans invaded and occupied some of
the eastern parts of the state
when the russian empire collapsed in the
wake of the bolshevik revolution its
forces left persia and the ottomans
would soon after go on to lose the war
and break apart
this left only britain who thanked
persia for its sacrifice and hard work
and made sure that as a result it would
be left independent forever more just
kidding
instead what happened was that britain
tried to make it into an unofficial
protectorate by enforcing its economic
hegemony there the ruler of persia at
this point ahmed shah agreed to these
terms because he didn't feel like dying
but they weren't implemented for very
long
this was because the us france and the
newly formed ussr decried the treaties
amounting to essentially annexation and
it was soon afterwards abandoned
and after this britain subsequently
withdrew leaving a somewhat independent
persia
thus iran did what many others failed to
do it survived the age of imperialism
and the reason why iran was never
conquered in its entirety was that it
played both britain and russia off
against each other
this meant that much of the country
would be under the effective economic
control of one of these two powers but
it did spur iran the same fate as places
like india or syria
which was something i hope you enjoyed
this episode and a special thanks to my
patreon supporters
james bissonette john lucid danny
maloney a man of culture
marvin castell john bisquez mo rob
waterhouse
james castaneda aaron the white jordan
longley gustav swann
marcus azner rasheed ali fielder oink
oink
izzy spinning three plates david
silverman maggie paxkowski
spencer lightfoot winston k wood robert
wetzel anthony beckett lexi schwinn sky
chappelle and kelly moneymaker
the occupation during world war ii
doesn't count